EU roads are the safest in the world
Parliament voted to improve road safety
even further by making 30 life-saving
technologies mandatory in all new models
from May 20-22
the EU losses up to nine point six
million euros in public procurement each
year due to a lack of whistleblower
protection members voted to ensure
whistleblowers have safe channels to
report wrongdoing consumers should have
the same rights whether buying a product
online or offline including remedies if
a product is defective under new rules
that the trader is liable if a product
becomes faulty within two years of
purchase there are three million EU
workers in gig economy type employment
parliament agreed measures ensuring
better working conditions including
preventing employers from stopping
workers taking other jobs and access to
free training members voted to launch a
nine point two billion euro programme to
shape Europe's future digital
transformation it will help fund
supercomputing AI technology cyber
security and digital skills for citizens